kicks off we have a min Reagan Kelly of
ipython i first ran into men online
through his his ipython parallel
tutorial which is I think to date the
best tutorial documentation of ever read
it was good right this is high five 2011
2010 it's that's funny because i've been
i've been wanting to rewrite that from
scratch for a lunch well that's those of
us that is my plan for syfy this year
that's awesome yeah men also built the
Piscean q bindings it also has a PhD in
physics so he's a pretty good at core
infrastructure so let's go is welcome
welcome in yeah alright so i'm glad to
be here PI data potatoes always is
always fun especially for those of us
who work on my python it's fun to see
everybody doing new and new and cool
stuff with like python yeah I recently
graduated in in plasma physics and now I
get to thanks to this one foundation I
along with a few other folks get to work
on my Python full time which is which is
pretty awesome so I'm gonna talk a
little bit about what's what's new and I
Python and recent release and then
what's coming kind of on the horizon for
people to be excited about so at on
April first we cut a Python 2 point 0
the first major release in six months
and there there are a few major new
features to improve the usability of the
notebook the the first piece of that is
if you've used the notebook in one point
O one of the things that was kind of
annoying is you had to start the
notebook every anytime you wanted to use
notebooks in a different place you had
to start another notebook server in that
directory and use and open the notebooks
there so one thing that we have that
we've added is simple directory
navigation in the notebook dashboard so
this is my this is my notebook dashboard
in addition to the old notebook list I
have a list of folders that are just
folders on my machines so I can navigate
to my presentation which
I data presentation and then I can see
the notebooks that I'm working on in
addition to this now that you can
navigate it's easy to lose track of what
notebooks are open what kernels are
running so you have this running tab
that shows you all the notebooks that
you have currently running and you can
shut them down so it's easier to clean
up clean up after yourself now that so
part of the goal of ipython is to kind
of fill all the gaps that you need to
restart the notebook server for
ultimately we really want there to only
be one notebook server running
ultimately on a machine at all for all
users but right now we want to get to
the point for one notebook server for
one user and let it let that be what you
use for for everything and not have to
restart the server so the kind of
flagship feature of a vibe Python 2 is
these interactive widgets and on Friday
Brian and John gave a tutorial
illustrating some of the some of the use
of interactive widgets and how you can
use them for your own work and Rob story
yesterday gave a great talk showing
various visualization things and one of
those was doing cool stuff with with the
interactive widgets cool stuff cooler
stuff than I'm actually going to show
you but so the interactive widgets let
you do things so in ipython generally
you know you run code you get output
here's a simple function that uses sim
pie to factor X to the N minus 1 well
what if I want to factor that for
various values of n you just use this
interact function and then I can
interact with fact with this factor it
function for values of n between two and
forty so now that's exit 21 I can just
move this slider and it calls that every
time I change the value of n it calls
the function again and then i get i get
the new display so this is really useful
for say you know you want to do some
filtering on a signal or something like
that and you don't necessarily know what
parameters you want to use this lets you
really simple
we say I I know I want these parameters
in some range let me just get it started
and then tweak the sliders and see you
know what values I actually want to use
interact also works as a decorator so
this is a function that that illustrates
the beat frequency between two
frequencies so when you have two
frequencies that are near each other you
get an Associated frequency of the
difference that you can hear kind of a
pulsing sound so this is using the
ipython html5 audio display so I just
take two two frequencies move these
sliders and then it publishes html5
audio after creating sine waves with
numpy then we can hear near be frequency
and change the frequencies it's lower be
frequency we also plot you can actually
see see the frequencies being plotted
and the beat frequency between them
that's updating much and I can just turn
turn that plot on and off with a little
checkbox we've got lots of widgets so
this is a small sampling of the widgets
we have she got checkboxes we got toggle
buttons we got regular clicky buttons we
have sliders for floats managers we've
got text input for four floats and
integers rape text input for texts text
areas for lots of texts radio buttons
all kinds of stuff basically any any of
the the basic HTML control elements
we've got a widget that maps that on to
python and so here i'm just going to
create a sampling of widgets and then
i'm going to display them and i've
created this text widget here and hooked
up a callback that in Python when I move
this it changes a value when I remove
the slider in JavaScript it changes a
value in Python of an object and I can
cook up event
for when that value changes I can call
this function and the function i call
just actually sets the value attribute
of my text widget to a string based on
what I just changed but then when i
change that python value it actually
sends the data to javascript and updates
the content of this text widget here so
i move the foot slider and shows me what
the float slider value is and the
insider tells me what I'm moving I can
use a select widget to select things of
radio buttons I can type some text and I
can select the weather with toggle
buttons like Unicode snowman that's the
sum of the gist of I did that's also a
good indication that are at least
Unicode isn't totally broken we still
occasionally run into run until Unicode
issues but I think we're doing pretty
well at this point another major change
in ipython to is what's the time another
major change in ni Python 2 is the UI in
the notebook in terms of keyboard
shortcuts and things as has been
rewritten substantially the result is it
is a modal you I so there's a command
mode and edit mode and to help people
get accustomed to this we've added a
using bootstrap tour for kind of getting
acquainted with the notebook I can
unhide my toolbar and grow the help menu
check out user interface tour so talk
about I got the menu bar at the toolbar
so they always look quite once all
zoomed mode indicator normally there
isn't something there but I have a
there's there's command mode and there's
edit mode and normally in command mode
there there isn't an indicator for what
mode you're in but I use a fighter jet
because of because it's fun so now I
mean I'm in command mode and
in edit mode i get a little pencil and
enter edit mode by pressing enter or
clicking with your mouse
yeah yeah the tour kind of shows you how
to do simple things one of the nice
things about the way we've rewritten it
in addition to fixing various various
bugs we had with the interaction with
jumping output and things is now it is a
lot easier to customize the behavior of
the notebook so this is some JavaScript
that is executing in the notebook I'm I
tell the colonel to publish this
JavaScript and then the front end
actually excuse this JavaScript on the
page and I'm going to on this I'm
registering an event to log all the keys
i press so you can see what I'm doing
without looking at my keyboard and then
I'm going to add this is it one of the
common feature requests we get on my
python is why isn't there a keyboard
shortcut for run all I want to keyboard
shortcut for run all and we've generally
said you know no we don't we can't have
a keyboard shortcut for everything be
especially in 1 dot x because of the way
keyboard shortcuts worked there was a
very limited space for for keyboard
shortcuts so we couldn't have a keyboard
shortcut for everything because it would
the the namespace for available
shortcuts was precious and the great
thing about the custom keyboard
shortcuts in 2 point 0 is we can say no
we're not going to add a keyboard
shortcut for run all but you can and so
if you want a keyboard shortcut for run
all you just add a little code to your
custom JavaScript and then you can press
ctrl R and it'll run all your cells and
and then we don't have to be Precious
about about what shortcuts are available
in club fighting with the browser
because users can say you know when i
press this i don't care about what my
browser wants to do what my OS wants to
do i I just want let me take this
shortcut and and use it to to run cells
you can also change there are there are
certain certain a certain class of users
when switching between edit mode and
command mode might prefer a slightly
different shortcuts
and so you can change in ipython
switching so you enter edit mode by
selecting a cell and press enter and
then to leave edit mode and go back to
command mode with the shortcuts as you
press escape but some people would
prefer say I to enter edit mode and some
people might prefer a control open
bracket to go go back to command mode so
with just a little bit of a little bit
of JavaScript that you can X that you
can put in your custom JS file so that
it runs every time on in every notebook
that you run you can change you can you
can change shortcuts you can remove
shortcuts you can add new shortcuts so
now if you look up by by the little jet
you can see what keys on typing so then
I clicked with my mouse now in edit mode
control Open bracket and command mode I
insert mode I mean edit mode so it's
it's a lot easier to customize the the
notebook UI which helps us at ipython a
lot because now we don't need to argue
about everything that's a night by thon
because we don't need ipython to be
everything for everybody we need ipython
to at least be a decent starting point
and then be able to point people in
directions to customize ipython to suit
their needs with the increasing amount
of JavaScript development in doing
things with ipython front-end
visualization with tools like MPL d3 and
Vincent and bouquet you increasingly you
need to get JavaScript on the page which
means increasingly you need to install
some JavaScript you don't to be loading
everything from a CDN all the time so
night python to we've added a notion of
notebook extensions so if I just look at
files I've got this just demo javascript
file which is a JavaScript file that is
from my notebook extensions on github I
can look at it's a it looks like the
kind of the top of
a standard required j/s loaded loaded
file and then we've added make sure make
sure it's not already there so if either
this install and be extension entry
point so this file is just on disk and
I'm just calling after the command line
I Python install and B extension and
what that does is it copied the
javascript file in the folder into this
special NBD extensions directory so if
you're familiar with I pie python has a
notion of extensions which are Python
modules that you can add to extend the
functionality of ipython and they're
just regular Python modules that define
one function that I that when you load
an extension it imports that module and
then calls that function and that
function can customize ipython behavior
this includes things like the are magic
or the SQL magic various things for
extending I pythons behavior so we added
a notion of JavaScript extensions for
the notebook extensions that should
modify that can modify ipython the
JavaScript side so similarly similar to
the load extension magic on the Python
side I can call load extensions
JavaScript function this is again
something put in custom jas so you
install an extension it's available to
all your notebooks but it's not loaded
on all your notebooks that's got to be
something you do in notebooks or in
profiles and then if I put this in my
custom ojs or call it here if you if you
look up in the corner note the absence
of anything next to this this code
select if I load this extension I got a
button what does that button do looks
like the standard share icon if i hover
it says share notebook is just click it
something may or may not happen yes okay
always risk and now I have this link so
i can click that link which will take me
two ND viewer so this is now i'm at NB
viewer this is a public website for
sharing notebooks and now i have the
notebook
I'm currently working on published as a
gist so that's what this is the kind of
the category of things you can do with
with extensions you can add buttons you
can do all kinds of customization of
ipython and X so and so on extensions
makes them available and then you can
load them with either with require so
you can either you can you can use
require to load things like d3 or
whatnot and extensions directory or you
can use this load extension thing which
is basically just like a Python
extension is import and then call a
special function the load extension in
javascript is require and then call a
special function the last bit is
notebook security so in the notebook the
notebook can have arbitrary code
arbitrary JavaScript that JavaScript
runs on the page that JavaScript can run
code which means that JavaScript can
call back to Python and that then that
Python can do you know arbitrary things
as you like rmr f / unpleasant things
but also those unsafe things are the
entire point of ipython like I ipython
doesn't the point of my python is not to
be safe the point about Python is just
to make it easier for you to do all the
things you normally do so we don't want
a crippled ipython but what what we
really but we do want to do is avoid
where we have a problem is when you open
a notebook that's creating a page with
HTML and JavaScript and that that
context has the ability to execute code
what we really don't want to do is if
someone writes a note book says hey
here's this cool notebook and you open
it you haven't you haven't run any code
you just open it and then it executes
code and all you did was look at it you
thought you're just looking at a thing
and then um code executed that that you
you didn't ask to happen so we've added
a bit of security to the notebook
document and that's we have this notion
of trusted and untrusted HTML and
JavaScript
and we never want to run untrusted we
never want to load untrusted HTML on the
page and we never want to execute
untrusted JavaScript which means that we
sanitize HTML when we add it to the page
and we that we don't trust and the gist
of model is if you didn't ask for it to
happen then it's not trusted so and the
way we communicate this is with a
signature on the notebook document so if
I write a notebook and give it to you it
won't be trusted but if you execute each
so if you hit shift enter to execute the
code that HTML that comes back that's
trusted you ask for that to happen it's
on you if it does something unsavory
just like running running a Python
script like you grab a Python script you
open it it's safe to look at it once you
trust it you run it it can at that point
it can do whatever and we want to get as
close to that as we can one of the
trickier parts of this is we consider
markdown the markdown areas like this we
consider those untrusted always and that
that that does limit what what can be
done in the markdown cell at this point
where we're working on kind of what
exactly our security model should should
do with that and we handle all of the
Sam cessation with goot the Google kaha
JavaScript soundstation library so
what's coming in the future for ipython
so first and foremost um starting a
notebook with the pilot flag was as a
master no longer works and this is
because there has been well this is
because of a variety of reasons when
decoupling loading a bunch of stuff so
pile a blow is a bunch of stuff into the
interactive namespace and that can cause
a great deal of confusion for users
because it matters how the notebook
server was started how how the server
was started can affect how notebooks
behave and that's a problem especially
when you're sharing notebooks or you
know if I started the notebook with
pylab once and then I started a
different notebook server without pylab
I run one notebook from the other i won
I run one notebook and then I run it
later with different start up flags and
it behaves totally differently do you
think it's generally not a great idea to
to have that kind of thing at startup
but also as we increase support for non
Python kernels adding specifying flags
for how the the Python subprocess where
execution happens makes less and less
sense so we're just the only specify
only configure the server at the ipython
notebook command line and then you any
any configuration of the colonel happens
elsewhere and part of that is part of
that effort is better support for non
Python kernels so you there already
right now are several kernels in in
various languages if you want to use the
notebook but you don't actually want to
use Python which may be a smaller
fraction of this crowd but you can you
can easily Python notebook with a
variety of languages and but it's where
we're and we're working on improving
that situation so here's a Julia example
simple Fibonacci and then as is always
fun this is using matplotlib from julia
to to create a an inline plot in like
Python notebook in three-point oh we're
going to be cleaning up a variety of
things for making better a non Python
Colonel support that includes cleaning
up the message spec cleaning up the
notebook format and a better
configuration for expressing what
associating a notebook with the colonel
I can say this is a Julia notebook when
I open it it should start a julia
colonel not a Python colonel this is the
start of the start of this spec is a
simple JSON file saying how you start
you know so so metadata about the
colonel and then the important piece is
how you actually start the colonel
sub-process we've got a bunch of changes
to the message back we've had a lot of
Python and I Python specific stuff we
found in how front ends
two kernels and Paul and Thomas from my
Python talked about how the my suspect
works yesterday if you want to check
that out and we're cleaning up a lot of
the things that our ipython and Python
specific to make it a bit more friendly
to the to the non Python kernels we're
also going to update the notebook format
and we're going to an important point of
this if you've been a long time user of
ipython we have today's an open forum at
once before now is a horribly painful
experience and we're going to work
pretty hard to make it not so not so
painful this time static widgets we're
going to have when you have a widget
like this one this is drawing a graph
you know with various numbers of nodes
various levels of connectedness this
doesn't work on NB viewer I because the
the widgets are purely transient they're
not stored in the notebook file or not
sort anywhere they're they're purely
interactive so we're going to add some
some amount of persistence book simple
persistence for loading for when you
open a notebook you get a widget and
then also caching all the various states
of the widgets and their output so that
you can actually interact without a
colonel so NBD viewer you just have
static HTML moving these sliders
normally call Python code in the back
end but the results are known so if you
just did a sweep and then remember it
all those outputs you could save them
somewhere and then you could have a
static HTML with all the cash States and
then you could still have those sliders
without actually running any code and
get all that output back and then the
big piece is the multi-user server so
we're you know we've been polishing the
single user notebook experience for for
a couple years now I think we're doing
pretty well and adding multi-language
support is kind of the last big piece of
that the next step is all right so we've
got we're getting pretty close to being
able to run one notebook server per user
for on that machine the next step is all
right we want to run 14 for these case
of say a classroom or a research group
you have you start up as the admin you
start up in a notebook server and then
users login with the
keeler unix credentials and then it
spawns sub processes so that the the
users get access to their whole shell
and notebook and everything and not just
they just hit hit one web page login it
starts the sub processes and then you
have your notebooks and kernels without
all your users having to you know SSH
and then start the notebook with no
browser background screen and all that
you can just with you know upstart or
whatever you just start up one even
process that will be in charge of
dispatching and proxying the Colonel's
an important point of this is that it is
not part of our plan to build a
multi-user server for untrusted users or
lots and lots of users you know we just
want to cover kind of the basic case of
a design of having multiple users it
starts you're on a shared system you
have trusted users that once the login
is then they should be able to do
anything they can do as them that it is
it is kind of up to Linux to to decide
what they're allowed to do and the next
big step that we have that we have on
the horizon once you get so we've got
republishing single user experience and
then we finish with the you know we
start getting multi-user going once you
got multiple users those users want to
work on the same notebook at the same
time and so that's kind of the next just
over the horizon the next big plan for
the hard project for us to work on is
live collaboration in a notebook then
I'm just going to spend the last couple
minutes talking about working on ipython
so I python is a started long ago by
Fernando as an afternoon hack working on
well working on his ph.d and as of
january of last year we have funding for
six full-time people to work on work on
ipython which includes how many of us
are here five everybody but Fernando
who's funding is here
Fernando is on a plane from England
right now I think at this very moment so
just looking at a few some some get data
about recent history of ipython this is
just looking at summarizing recent
releases so 0 dot 11 was the first kind
of partially funded release of ipython
where Brian was funded by and thought to
kind of to refactor to clean up a lot of
the afternoon hacky bits of a vibe
Python and allow and set the the
groundwork for this multi-process
architecture that is that underlies the
notebook and since then and then in 2013
which was halfway between 13 and 1 point
0 we started actually having funding for
the first time for multiple developers
to work and are since then in 2 point 0
which is a six-month release our kind of
rate of work has well read it for you
we've we do get a lot more work done now
that we're funded is is kind of the gist
that's so thanks for the sloan
foundation for actually helping us get
work done but a challenge when you have
funded developers and but you have a
small number of fun developers who have
a lot of work they want to do and you
get a popular project with a lot of
people want to use it and a lot of
people want to help out is you know we
still have all these contributions that
are coming from volunteers and
volunteers don't have as much time as
fun to developers so you know you get
someone who you get people who open open
pull requests or like that's it's it's
so great that you're you want to help
out it's the contribution is is really
helpful but we have all these plans that
actually conflict with that in that we
actually haven't gotten around to right
so we've we've got these big plans we've
got developers who have time to work but
we don't actually have that many so we
don't have that much time to work so we
have we
up with these conflicts of someone wants
to fix something but we actually plan to
totally change how that works and it's
been a challenge to actually figure out
how we deal with contributions when we
have you know we have this time to work
on things and we have big plans and so
you want to make sure you visualize pull
request these are pull requests on
github that have actually been merged so
this is funding starts right here and
after a bit of ramp up in the spring the
pull request room from core devs from
funded people has dramatically increased
and the contribution the actual
successful contribution rate from the
community is is roughly roughly stable
and the-- so the fraction of polar quest
was from community members was roughly
half but the as core dev development
court have work has dramatically
increased and community development has
roughly stayed flat the diffraction from
the community is has dropped a little
bit so I'm actually um yeah I've talked
about about communication balance but I
only i'll leave the last five minutes
for questions so I'll stop here but yeah
the last last little bit is the dream
for the future of ipython so I python is
a growing number of things for working
for doing interactive work it makes
sense at this point that it's all one
big project because every up so far
every update would be a breaking change
that would we would need to release
every piece of ipython if a person were
several projects we would need to
release them all at once because they're
not inter compatible with you know we
make these internal private api changes
every release and so it doesn't make
sense at this point to to break up by
python as we're still since we're still
figuring out so much but we're getting
closer to kind of understanding the the
boundaries between these pieces and once
those
k belies a bit kind of the real dream in
ipython is actually to break it up into
several several projects that just talk
to each other over the message protocol
you know the ipython Colonel becomes
just another colonel just like the ark
colonel the Julia colonel and break off
no the cutie consoles its own project
ipython parallels its own project and so
that is if we are successful in
stabilizing ap is the one way to know if
I python has been really successful is
if it explodes into into a few separate
separate repositories in the next few
years Michael stop there any question so
if someone wanted to contribute to
ipython what is the best method that
they should use the best method um the
best method to use for contributing
ipython is to look at open issues and
find so we mark some bugs is like quick
fix or dead art or sprint friendly those
are those are things yeah we have labels
on issues that are kind of meant to be
small s easy things to fix the fix that
don't need to touch all kinds of stuff
and so that's look through some of those
issues actually a really helpful way so
we've got you know these almost 800
issues is so issues and antsy do they
are they still actually true does this
have we fixed this issue and you know
ping you know look for right test cases
regression tests you know find an issue
actually write a test so that it's
easier to know whether a bug has been
fixed if it has been fixed just make a
PR with the test and close that issue
you know that one of the challenges with
having lots of lots of open issues is we
don't always we don't always link up bug
fixes to the issues that they actually
fix so there there are probably of the I
think 750
780 currently open issues i would say
there's probably at least one or two
hundred that should be just closed right
now and we just know what they are I'll
take okay good I'm really interested in
I Python parallel can you talk a little
bit about the sort of i've heard in the
ether that like a hundred a hundred
kernels is all that is advisable does
that mean a hundred independent servers
or if i've got two really big servers
with like sixty four cores each is that
more stay so it depends it depends on so
the issue there a couple of so I have so
I pero was mostly my work that's that
was my the first type island peril was
my undergrad thesis at Santa Clara and
then I rewrote at T 0 mq while I was
working on zeromq and right now because
of some architectural choices the limit
of good scaling is probably one two
three depending on the nature of the
work you want to run one two three
hundred ipython engines which are
ipython processes and the number of
those that's appropriate depends on what
work you want to do so if if your work
is you know nice you know sea level
multi-threaded array operations you
might want one ipython engine / physical
cpu with you know 16 cores or something
and the the scaling limit is affected by
the number of ipython engines so it
depends on the nature of your of your
individual tasks that you want to do a
night python peril so if it's all like
Gil holding effectively single-threaded
then you generally want one engine perc
perc or or even if it's i/o bound maybe
one and a half engines per core but if
you've got good multi-threaded extension
code maybe you want you know one per
chip or one per physical machine so cute
a little bit about the memory
issue and dyeing processes if you if you
launch a hundred kernels and one dies
does it respond if if it stays open for
a bunch of tasks does it kill itself and
release the memory so you can I Python
doesn't handle that it's so the cluster
behaves fine if an engine dies you can
you can add and remove engines at any
point and the type I think pro
architecture handles that just fine what
it doesn't do is so IP engine just
starts a process listens for messages
and handles them if you start IP engine
with supervisor or something you can
make it kill it if it gets too big and
respawn when it dies so I Python doesn't
do that for you but you can easily
enough do that with ipython great um we
need to wrap up now for the next talk
can everybody give men a huge hand give
us a couple minutes we'll have the next
speaker up
I really want